so biden you know we're used to him
misreading the teleprompter or
forgetting what he's saying or going
with the crazy story or making up words
or anything else but here was a gaffe
that happened a little bit uh later
after obama and former first lady
michelle obama spoke
biden didn't even have to speak and
still screwed something up
joe honestly everybody stood with joe
well first off that that poor sign
language lady having to laugh at this
but literally everyone in the room stood
up for jill for dr jill biden i don't
want to get in any trouble with dr jill
biden and joe forgot to stand up
robert is he going to make it is he
going to make it for the four years of
this thing or what i mean we're barely
two years in
i think they would like to remove them
but their problem is as almost every
poll shows with my buddy richard barris
of people's pundit basically everybody
out like you asked what is biden's best
asset he's not the alternative he's not
kamala harris you know he's not pete
butterjudge he's not hillary clinton
he's not gavin newsom uh when these
people pull against trump trump crushes
him and so they're they're stuck with
him they're stuck with a living walking
talking dementia candidate in the white
house and they can't find a way out of
it and they use him as a figurehead even
though he's an increasingly embarrassing
figurehead of the of the corrupt regime
that the white house now represents
under the bible administration and its
incompetence as well but they don't have
a they don't have a backup that there's
no relief picture here to help there's
no backup quarterback to come in and
save them that's their problem
is it crazy amela how thin their bench
is that you know everyone knows biden is
compromised and you know i i said it the
day he was inaugurated i do i still
believe it i don't think he's gonna make
it all four years i don't see how it
won't just collapse at some point either
them forcing him out or him having like
a true full-on breakdown you know on
camera and they won't be able to hide it
anymore but that there as robert says
it's like kamala pulling at zero in her
own party when they plucked her for vp
nobody really likes gay pete like the
whole crew it's like there's there's
just nothing there
right i think they gave themselves away
too quickly and just normal reasonable
rational people of all sorts and of all
sides of the aisle cannot get behind
anybody who's on their roster and i want
to say something nice i have a lot of
sympathy for for jill biden for for
standing so strong and having to cover
up every single embarrassing gaffe that
happens with her husband i mean he
clearly doesn't stand unless told to
stand so i'm sort of with you dave i
don't know that he's going to make it
and that's not something that i'm
cheering on or excited about i i quite
literally feel bad for him that he's
being used as a puppet right now in his
presidency but that might be karma you
know for the record i think you can make
the complete reverse argument about jill
though because she knows if anyone knows
what's really wrong with him and
whatever drugs he's on or whatever
they're doing to him to prop him up
there she knows so in some ways i get
what you're saying about having sympathy
for her because it's embarrassing but in
another way it's like who's more evil in
this situation like is it the political
hack that's using him or obama or his
own wife that's using him spencer bring
us home on that positive note
well i mean i think you guys are all
just being way too unkind to biden all
they have to do is write stand up on his
little cheat sheet and no they have to
write the president stands up he always
the president stands up and you are the
president yes you the president joe
biden which is also you
stand up right i mean it's the staffer's
fault they're not no
i um
i am
nothing will surprise me at this point
and so i am agnostic i think about
whether he's going to make it whether
they can really force him through across
the finish line but i i think the point
about the thinness of the bench is
really crucial they have a serious
problem on their hands which is that all
the energy all the youth of the party is
concentrated in this tiny vanguard that
believes absolutely whack-a-doodle
bonkers crazy town things about the most
basic questions of human life like male
and female right or race even you know
things that are not just anti-american
but anti-common sense anti-human um and
and to put that out in front of a
political party is simply a no-go it's
simply you know not gonna fly they have
to do their best to warp the minds of
children into accepting it but that's
not going to pay off for another 20
years so what do they do you know they
have to find somebody that looks like a
normal dude
yeah they're the closest like analog the
next best thing is pete bootaj and you
know one shudders to think that that's
the closest thing they have to a normal
person i i don't know it's uh it's rough
it's rough going for them and
and i hope that they uh they suffer for
it politically
on that note i just like to say that the
three of you are three of my favorite
fascists and i hope you have i hope you
have a great weekend